The Cal ISO has started rotating power outages.
Governor Newsom today, address the recent rolling blackout.
We failed to predict and plan.
Energy conservation is what the California
Independent System Operator wants to see.
Any type of conservation...
The overall picture is that the California
grid ran out of energy.
Critics say California's rolling blackouts this summer
were caused by decades of costly and poorly
planned decisions to replace coal, nuclear,
and gas power plants with solar and wind.
Speaks to the delusion of California policy
makers.
They really convinced themselves that they
could manage all of this increased demand
on renewables, which are fundamentally unreliable.
Michael Shellenberger is the president of
Environmental Progress, which advocates for
greater reliance on nuclear power as a way
to reduce CO2 emissions and provide reliable energy.
California banned the construction of new
nuclear reactors in 1976 and has been incentivizing
companies to close older plants by piling
on burdensome regulation ever since.
Shellenberger says this loss has made California
more susceptible to blackouts.
We were looking at about a 4,000 megawatt
shortfall, the two nuclear plants, the one
that shut down and the one they want to shut
down, total 4,400 megawatts.
So it would have just provided the energy
that we didn't have.
The other thing is that the nuclear plant,
unlike the solar farms or the wind, is reliable
92% of the year, the only times you can't
have it is when you're adding new fuel to the plant.
Policymakers also started closing down natural
gas plants because they produce more CO2 emissions
than wind and solar, ignoring warnings that
doing so would lead to shortages.
And Governor Gavin Newsom recently signed
an executive order asking the state legislature
to ban gas fracking for oil and gas.
But the problem with wind and solar is that they
only provide consistent energy under
optimal weather conditions.
And they just shut down too many of them.
There's a lot of fancy dancing to explain
how it wasn't a result of renewables,
but it was fundamentally that the sun goes down
at the exact moment that peak demand starts
to climb.
But a major operator of California's grid says that it wasn't renewables like wind and solar
that caused the blackouts, but a lack of easily accessible back up energy.
Renewables have not caused this issue.
This is a resource issue, not a renewable
issue.
Some defenders of renewable energy even say
that fossil fuels are the real culprit and
and that critics like Shellenberger are distorting
the facts in service of their preconceived biases.
The August blackout, they point out, was directly
caused by the failure of a natural gas generator.
Those fossil fuel technologies have trouble
performing in the heat.
In fact, solar generation doesn't have trouble
Energy analyst Amol Phadke is the coauthor
of UC Berkeley's 2035 report, which argues
that America should transition to 90% carbon
free energy generation in the next 15 years.
But the natural gas generator that failed
was a backup system, which was flipped on
only because the state's energy capacity failed
as Californians blasted their air conditioners
to deal with a heat wave as the sun went down
and the wind slowed.
Those had to come online because they are
the backup for the renewables that-
Oh, those were kind of planned generation.
Okay.
The way you plan the power system is that,
you know the sun is going to set.
Phadke says the failure to adequately plan
back up power was the real problem.
And in fact, I would argue that having lot
more renewable energy and storage will make
the grid even more robust.
As California has increased its reliance on
renewable energy, it has also become increasingly
reliant on energy imported from neighboring
states.
They're counting on their neighbors too much,
and those neighbors need their power plants
cause they're hot too.
Engineer and investor Mark Mills is a faculty
fellow at Northwestern University and a senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute.
He says that California's push to replace
traditional power plants with renewables has
created a shortage of what's known as dispatchable
capacity, or generators that can be flipped
on when there's a spike in demand.
What would happen in a normal grid is another
gas turbine would fire up and there'd be no blackout.
What happened in the first blackouts is that
they didn't have dispatchable capacity,
and worse than that, there was a wind lull, so
simultaneous to the gas turbine not coming online,
then you have to force blackouts to keep
the rest of the grid lit.
None of that would have happened if you were
using conventional capacity.
And the more wind you add, the less dispatchable
you have, the more likely you'll have those
events occur cause you'll have fewer and fewer
dispatchable assets.
It's simple logic.
Phadke says the solution is for California to build even more solar power plants,
and invest more money in giant batteries that can store power from the wind and sun during off hours.
In the long run, if you have enough batteries
to transfer that solar energy during the day
into the evening hours, you are good.
And the good news is that the cost of those
batteries has dropped by 90% since 2010.
The constant babbling about batteries is an
embarrassing failure to understand arithmetic.
Mills has calculated that storing a barrel
of oil's worth of energy in a battery
costs at least a hundred times as much.
And that it would take about a thousand years
for the world's largest battery factory
to produce enough to store just two days worth
of America's energy needs.
Batteries are never going to get cheaper to
store energy than storing oil in a barrel
until we develop a room temperature superconductor,
which doesn't exist, could exist in theory,
and could become cheap in theory, sometime.
If that ever happens, we could store electricity
as cheap as oil in a barrel.
Changes the world.
Mills also points out that the intensive mining required to produce batteries has a major environmental cost.
Wind and solar are very diffuse energy sources.
So the amount of land required is order of
magnitude 10 to 30 times more than for hydrocarbons.
Because they're diffuse energy sources, you
have to build lots of machines.
And when you build lots of machines, you have
to mine more stuff.
America doesn't like mines anymore so we depend
on mines as most people by now know, Cobalt
half of it's mined in Democratic Republic
of Congo, Chinese mine the rare earths,
we don't anymore.
The biggest nickel mines in the world are in the Arctic and Russia,
Australia does a lot of the mining for the world.
We can mine more, but the increase in mining
that the green energy path will require
will be the biggest increase in mineral extraction
the world has ever seen.
Instead of producing our own oil and gas and
energy, which is 80% of our energy, we will
import energy minerals from somebody else
that will increase imports,
increase strategic dependencies, increase deficits.
You may think that's fine, but it's a real
cost that no one's counting.
It's dishonest.
But the 2035 report estimates the cost of
not quickly pivoting to renewables
at $1.2 trillion in health and environmental damages and 85,000 premature deaths by 2050.
It recommends a combination of emission standards,
government subsidies, and tax incentives
to ramp up solar, wind, and battery production as quickly as possible.
Why not just say we're going to set a standard
and then however you get there,
figure that out, rather than tipping the scale towards solar and wind?
Yeah, I think that's the first best option.
I would say that I think the simplest option,
but which is not politically acceptable,
is tax the polluters.
I mean, you have to pay your fair share of
what damage you do.
But Shellenburger says that nuclear would provide
the clean and abundant energy that both sides want.
If only California and other states
would stop creating incentives for them to
close down, and allow new ones to open up.
Just keeping the nuclear plants online would
have kept prices down significantly.
If California had a vision of being like France, 75% nuclear, getting our cooking and heating from electricity,
well that could be a very good deal for both consumers and the natural environment.
But nobody's talking about that.
And Mill says that ironically, the technological
innovations that would be required to fulfill
the environmentalists' dreams, rely on continuing
to have abundant energy right now.
If you want to go from propellers to jet engines,
if you want to go from combustion to nuclear fission,
if you want those kinds of phenomenology
changes, if you want to store electricity
as cheap as we store oil, you need a different,
whole new solution.
Because we always have new discoveries, but
they don't come from directed development
where a government says, "make that wind turbine
better, build me more wind turbines."
To get the kinds of shifts that people are
talking about in society, to get something
as profound as discovering of nuclear fission,
takes discoveries in basic science.
So you produce energy at the least possible
cost to have as much profit to invest in basic
science and invest in adaptation and resilience.
There's a respectable chance a lot of America
will follow in California's path.
I think that's the path we're on.
This is what their plan is.
So, if you are concerned about the blackouts,
the six-fold increase in electricity prices,
the bad management of our electrical grid
that causes fires in places where we should
have less fires, not more then, yeah, you should be concerned about what's happening in California
and not want it to be imposed
on the rest of the U.S.